seventeen-year-old Esters tried to
balance her second year of high school
in montprusi in Northern Ghana with
being a new mother
while one in three pregnant girls don't
return to school Esther says she is
determined to complete her education
I want to be a doctor
and I will work hard to achieve that
goal
while Esther gets some help from her
mother a government programs also
supporting her return to class
Ghana is one of 38 African countries
working to educate pregnant girls or
mothers about the benefits
the program was implemented five years
ago more than ten thousand girls have
gone back to school many take their
babies too
those days that uh it was not
permissible or it was not allowed for
them to come back with a pregnancy some
when they got pregnant in a way they try
to terminate they don't lose their life
it will affect them in future in varying
children so that policy has actually
helped this time they are free to come
to school they don't even feel shy they
sit in Classics with their colleagues
and they learn they were 82 pregnancies
in this municipality alone during the
last Academic Year many here are poor
which often contributes to the high teen
pregnancy rate you have three or four
people mother five children living in
the same room
some of them I do listen
you have gotten to the Sea where they
have some of these challenges coming up
so
because they are crowded in their rooms
they are forced to go out in England put
their colleagues and put them into some
of these things exactly
Ghana's government says more than half a
million teenagers became pregnant
between 2016 and 2020 some just 10 years
old
while free education in Ghana means nine
out of 10 children are enrolled in
primary schools almost a third drop out
due to pregnancy
the government hopes awareness campaigns
will encourage more young women such as
Esther to stay in school despite the
challenges of being a new mother she's
also planning to complete her education
too familiar Al Jazeera